green chemistry is the design of
chemical products and processes that
reduce and eliminate the use and
generation of hazardous substances we're
really in this wonderful space of having
these inventions that you can apply all
across chemistry to to destroy things
and Anna and really a metaphor for what
we've actually got is like fire in water
in other words you can take chemicals
you don't want and put them in a very
sophisticated and incinerator and burn
them at very high temperatures and they
will go away right but you can't do that
in water because of course the water
would just boil well with our catalyst
and hydrogen peroxide you get exactly
the same result you take these molecules
that are not don't go away easily in
nature that lasts and water forever
essentially on many years and years and
water or in the environment and tamil
peroxide or hammer them to oblivion in
in minutes at room temperature
with tiny quantities of the tamil
catalyst and small amounts of hydrogen
peroxide so so we're in this really
wonderful space of knowing that we have
solutions to real world problems
you